Brad Pitt and Angelina Jolie have begun
to unload their real-estate holdings the
first casualty their home in New Orleans
we're living here now I mean we we're a
nomadic family pretty much but we got a
base here definitely that base just sold
for 4.9 million dollars and the now
estranged couple made a pretty good
profit a million plus they purchased the
French Quarter mansion for 3.5 million
back in 2007 it has seven thousand six
hundred forty five square feet and three
bathrooms
the couple cleverly listed the estate
under the mondo Bongo trust which is one
of the songs they danced to and mr. and
mrs. Smith the movie where they first
met they wanted to get rid of the house
Brad and Angelina actually cut the price
by eight hundred thousand dollars at one
point and then wound up selling it for
far less than they were asking they
grabbed the property after Hurricane
Katrina hey what's up man no thanks for
coming out of here making the trip for
it's variable Brad showed me around the
housing project he helped develop in the
city's Lower Ninth Ward symbolically
it'll be putting the neighborhood back
together the couple has already put
their French mansion and vineyard
Chateau Miraval on the market they paid
an estimated 60 million dollars for the
property it's a challenging property to
be selling because it's a business so
what's next in the divorce sell-off well
the couple owns another vineyard Villa
Costanza in Italy it's worth 41 million
in West London they own a 16 million
dollar home and Brad has a 5,300 square
foot home in Los Angeles
keep in mind Brad Pitt bought this back
in 1994 long before he ever met Angelina
so it's possible that for many reasons
including sentimental ones he'll wanna
hang on to it